oui apprenti Cavazos canule interne accessible
précoce m.  Popple
école sévère Opoku Virginiens applaudir nerado
recevoir Rohini illa billah ' Lucy
Georgina est une invitée permanente de Garuda Kate
Bush
Berlin a toujours été très ouverte d'esprit et
il y avait beaucoup d'espace tous les artistes
voulaient déménager ici parce que vous aviez la
liberté tant d'espace dans  la ville où
il suffit de trouver un mur à peindre ou d'aller
à de beaux concerts et c'est toujours pareil
tout le monde vient à Berlin parce que c'est
toujours une ville où il fait bon vivre et
ouvert d'esprit ils ont la liberté
métro jaune toits rafidhi musique vie nocturne
fêtes sauvages multi culture  tu peux te
promener et en voir un tu peux porter ce que tu
veux tu peux avoir l'air comme tu veux tu n'as pas
besoin d'avoir une grosse voiture ou beaucoup d'
argent personne ne s'en soucie donc tu peux juste
vivre comme tu aimes vivre
[Musique]
un  en haut cela signifie une puissance unie
c'est tout l'équipage toute l'équipe ensemble
nous agissons juste unis globalement nous parcourons
le monde entier peignons ensemble nous cachons
notre identité parce que nous peignons aussi des
trains parfois illégaux au fil des ans
10 ou 15 ans, nous avons fait plus que 10
des 15 tours et graffitis bombardements
pièces peintures murales trains nous essayons d'avoir un
bon message message positif il y a
tellement de choses étranges dans le monde en ce
moment tant de guerres tant de résistance
tant de haine et  nous essayons de montrer aux gens
qu'il est aussi bon de rester unis pour faire des
projets ensemble l'art peut être un
langage international tout le monde
comprend l'art tout le monde sait
dessiner sur un papier la chose la plus facile
à faire parfois vous n'avez pas besoin de parler
avec les gens  quand vous ne connaissez pas la
langue vous allez juste ensemble sur le
mur vous peignez les enfants viennent ils peuvent
peindre avec vous ensemble c'est une
manière internationale de
tragédie communautaire d'un village émotionnel méchant un
marié comme élitiste pour graphique et méchant
un double New Orlean  l'oppresseur est une
année analogique comme graphique oui je vous demande vendu
très studieusement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous avions une zone d'étincelles de toilettes qui était
l'ancienne station spatiale des Américains
sur les Russes après la guerre Secon  d
World War
maintenant, celui-ci est la galerie à espace ouvert
pour les graffeurs et donc les gens peuvent
venir ici et travailler, donc c'est
définitivement un symbole que nous n'avons pas besoin de toutes
ces guerres folles dans le monde, nous avons juste
besoin de gens qui sont comme  créatif
trouver de nouvelles voies et la liberté plus de
frontières
cela ne veut pas dire non plus des milliards Christ
tu n'es pas bon ici tu es une star clé
Alice chère Amira c'était Tony me
regarde ça arrive liste via le propriétaire de la star évitez-moi
c'est difficile de  dites ce que la guerre signifie pour
nous parce que nous n'avons jamais vécu dans une guerre, mais c'est
certainement la pire chose qui
puisse arriver dans une guerre, nous sommes totalement
contre la guerre, nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi toute la société se bat toujours et
nous ne  pas besoin de guerre la manœuvre de Linnaeus
plus Castilla ici à une fille au
sirop à oh bonne résolution est dunya est
la réciprocité des ennemis accostés
Falacci pas moins
ahem je crois vraiment que ce que vous dites est
passé Ana Lucia Kotori vous avez vu Damien une
raison pour laquelle vous gay Luigi  lasagnes Sue Ellen
vivrait plus tard projeto stone est
matryona Sabri de nombreux designs chaque répartiteur de mémoire
ooh et insérez Akiko Suzuki
star OVA un poignard ou juste quelques
milliards de cas Jimmy crew a rejeté le
cutter un whammy certes je le connaissais alors
il a dit à Kaitlyn iam so Tommy opéras illa
billah Nia Agora maniaquement  Crysta
graphique e ma logistique Oprah sur la
sévérité de Pattaya par obv un miroir qu'un petit
Pablo Picasso pas une technique de torture
Athena Katarina costume un
associé brésilien Lorena costume Emerson Ilana
Bruce KU mojos tromper semestre à Cal
namaha Jose Veras race nous choisissons pour mrs.
moi parti moutoku kazoo
diplômés pour toi ouais bravo pour ta
période nerveuse Alicia ici
[Musique
] c'était vraiment important pour nous de faire
ce projet parce que c'est comme une
chose vraiment importante exactement à cette
époque où il y a beaucoup de guerre à l'intérieur
de ce mot  à propos de la religion de l'argent ou d'un
intérêt différent et tout le
monde oublie toujours qu'il y a la
paix c'est la seule chose qui
nous réunira tous nous unira tous
si nous arrêtons de faire la guerre
arrêtons de produire des armes arrêtons de chasser le pétrole arrêtons de tuer des gens  alors nous
aurons une société paisible et agréable et un
mot agréable à écouter où vous aimeriez tous
faire grandir vos enfants aujourd'hui, nous avons
peint le mot simple morceau et des
morceaux russes et une chose vraiment importante à laquelle
tout le monde devrait penser et nous aussi
à des mots différents avec le
langage international tel que nous le mettons pour
différents pays que c'est comme un
mot ou une compréhension globale, nous utilisons le
fond spécial aujourd'hui pour écrire le
diff  érentes lettres dans les différentes
langues qui ont un historique et
qui sont également visibles dans l'étiquette de riz
par exemple pour la guerre est finie elle a un
fond spécial donc nous l'avons encore utilisé
aujourd'hui dans notre pièce sur le toit la plupart
du temps les gens ne le font pas  Je n'aime pas parler
de problèmes de société pour que les artistes puissent
transmettre ce message à travers le street
art et cela devrait les laisser commencer à
réfléchir à des problèmes généraux ou à des
solutions pour le monde que nous pouvons tous
vivre en paix un jour
[Musique]